hey guys justin hey Walt here with a
gamespot news update some Philadelphia
gamestop stores have started
fingerprinting people who come in to
trade in games to help prevent crime
according to gamestop local laws allow
them to collect thumb prints which are
then provided to law enforcement helping
them prevent gamestop from being used as
a pawn shop of sorts according to
philadelphia city solicitor shelley
smith gamestop is not required to
collect thumb prints because the
pawnbroker laws do not apply to them the
Philadelphia Police Department tells CBS
Philadelphia that gamestop is being
proactive by acquiring fingerprints and
uploading them to the database known as
leads online game stop shoppers are not
particularly thrilled about the new
policy I really don't appreciate it one
person said you fingerprinted me like
I'm in a police district no I'm at a
game store another shopper said I think
it's an overreach it's going too far the
future is coming there's no word yet on
whether gamestop is also going to be
forming private militias but we'll keep
you updated here at gamespot com